so
[Music]
turn this
all right so uh i i can't wrestle
him all right so his
his initial energy there's a yield and
then boom
there is a ground vectoring there's a
cochlea
yield pop and then when i do that i
don't need tension in my arms
easy
so first of all you produce it and then
you're gonna have another one
when he comes around so i'm just i'm
just guiding this
he comes around come around like you
mean it
oh and he'll hit your hand as he tries
to get his height
i'm not here shoving this down i wait
for him to get up
that's what causes that then here
i move to where that's going to be in
place
i don't turn this i move to where it's
going to be
and then i'm just waiting for him to
come around
so boom around
up help you move in place wait for him
so no contestation
don't wrestle this down
go around go around
go around boom
it's subtle but it's there oh
go around it
here
so the concept of wu wei is not to do
anything yet it happens okay so
but better to do the right action so do
the right
action that allows for what's happening
to happen
okay so uh when you're here
you get that second boom you
this this hand if you look at it
somewhere in space it's already in the
nicu
on my shoulder okay
but i can move in some weird places
where it's not
so this right where it is
that's where i'm going to try to put my
shoulder okay
i mean how it is don't move it don't
require any grip strength
by leaving it where it is and instead
move where that goes without any turning
of it
right here i want it to be
where i don't have to turn it i don't
need any strength at all
and then when i get here then i have
this three contact grip okay
and again if he stays here no problem
but
in the technique he comes around to a
grass and that's when he puts himself in
the technique
so
in this
leave it where it is feel whether you
need torque
or thumb pressure or grip pressure and
that
where you move where you don't have
those things
that's where enikio is
[Music]
all right so here you have this
small window of opportunity okay
and you're not gonna crank this guy
you're not gonna get it so you just stop
it from going down
okay and you go around it you see
then you continue this fire
i'm moving this way
then it's on my body my body my body's
doing it
okay i'm holding it
[Music]
then like always elbows on the front
side of your spine
never on the back side of your spine
front side of your spine
[Music]
here
front side is fine lands there
[Music]
here
i'm exaggerating it
front side is fine
don't just do that with your hands
in the yin-yang world they go through
phases you have to complete the phase
one phase before you go to the next
phase but you don't go
past the completion of the previous
phase okay so
uh boom you're coming around
and then you lose the arm this is too
far away
okay and then he comes up
and then you go do that but it's when
you when when the arm
when you come around and he drops out of
your elbow that's when you come up
you see so you're not there's no time
when you're you're kind of like this
he'll pop out of my grip boom and i come
up to the
to the wrist so i don't lose contact
movement is relaxed but there's an
internal aspect so
i i could do like i could go i didn't
relax
and there's no concussion to him see
there's no progression because there was
a concussion right
so we're going to go to standing because
you can see it
because his energy is coming into me i'm
bouncing off the ground and
cook you in it out okay so say thank you
[Music]
okay